prends-en deux hey Mark
alors fais-le venir ici tous les jours et
lire tous les livres qu'il peut car le
sort interdit ne l'a pas trouvé il n'a
rien trouvé mais tu peux le faire
Dieu nous donne ce que nous pouvons gérer même
si nous ne le croyons pas nous-mêmes
respire donne-moi les mains
ferme les yeux vois avec ton esprit ce que
tu cherches comme si tu l'avais déjà
trouvé
c'est
un bébé très spécial
tu as
quelque chose de
mal à plus tard
je ne sais pas et si vous vous retournez tous et
sentez ce trafic complet rapidement d'accord d'
accord essayons
cette application d'arrière-plan mais cessez-le-feu
hé où est Ava super breyer foutez le camp
ici  fille d'accord les gars
Megan a dit que c'était la seule façon de
te protéger c'est son idée elle m'a dit que
tu devenais sombre de toute façon je ne te ferais jamais de
mal tu te souviens quand je suis parti donc je
ne te ferais pas de mal bien tu sais
tu sais que tu es  beaucoup plus comme moi que
tu ne veux l'
admettre  Je vais danser en
attente
mesdames et messieurs c'est une
fin d'image pour vous manquer à Emma Thompson